les anciens disent chaque décision qu'on
prend aujourd'hui a des répercussions
sur les sept prochaines générations
ne laisse jamais dans ces coulées où les
rêves qui sont apportées
red eye est désactivé il est désactivé
oui mais il est toujours un star nous
sommes constitués de nos expériences red
eye à la lentille de contact qui
enregistre non pas ce que l'oeil peut
voir mais ceux dont l'esprit se souvient
lycées pas encore très voici le nouveau
red eye
actuellement on a beaucoup plus de
questions sur sa mort que de réponses
vous allez déverrouiller un casque pour
moi ce que faisait elissa a réveillé
quelque chose là
à la vérité pourtant là mais on n'arrive
pas encore à la voir
il un problème avec le nouveau réveil
pourquoi ne pas vous montrer directement
c'est parti je dois devenir comme vous
plus il passe quoi là il ya un truc qui
cloche avec médaille il manipule les
souvenirs qu'est-ce qui l'alimentent
l'adrénaline la sérotonine elle nous
exploite lui a eu une autre vision je
sais plus si elles sont réelles ou pas
je des programmes et c'est moi qui te
contrôler lui-même un nord
regarde ce que tu as créé